nation is less with the passing of John
McCain good man it's fairly easy for me
to look at anyone who's in leadership
anywhere but certainly in politics and
find things I disagree with them all the
thing we've lost is the ability to
disagree without being disagreeable I
post a simple thing rest in peace John
McCain courageous patriot whatever
something like that on Twitter yesterday
and I got hate about John McCain back
which gave me an excuse to sit and block
people on my Sunday afternoon had
anything else to do so because if you're
so stupid
and classless and such a troll that
that's what you're gonna do I'll go
ahead and block you it's just sad you
guys I mean I don't agree with hardly
anything Barack Obama did but I don't
think he's a horrible man I don't think
he's a bad person and I'm not you know
and I'm not gonna spew hate at him
personally I can have a disagreement on
the substance without that same thing
with Donald Trump but my god you are
either for Trump or his right wing nut
followers will take you to the woodshed
or you're against Trump I mean if you're
for him the left wing nut jobs will go
after you or if you're for him
if you say anything positive about him
at all you know people come after you if
you say anything negative about them at
all people come after you why can you
not just go you know there's something
there's some things I agree with some
things I don't why can you not just do
that because we've lost our ability to
disagree without being disagreeable and
I don't I don't know where the social
media has revealed that or caused it I
don't know whether the 24-hour news
cycle has revealed that or caused it see
when I was a kid there CNN was the very
first one to come out and do 24-hour
news and we thought nobody's gonna watch
it in those 24 hours a day is the
dumbest idea Ted Turner's gonna go
of course he made a mint and CNN was the
big dog till Fox came along and knocked
them out but I mean this 20 this need to
feed and their web sites have gotten
where they look like the National
Enquirer space-alien Beyonce has baby of
space-alien is on the Fox web site I
mean it's like what are you guys putting
on and you open up CNN and they have the
most bizarre stuff like you used to see
in the checkout aisle on National
Enquirer and they report it as if it's
like real news I don't on my fake news
I'm just saying it's just bizarre how
the the lowest common denominator has
really come out I mean it's the bottom
of the barrel and you don't believe me
just will pick up any article about
almost anything and if you really want
to know why some species eat their young
read the comments below the article it's
just some of the dumbest angriest
craziest people with some of the most
ridiculous statements in the world
following somebody because they have the
they have the benefit of anonymity and
so they have what we call digital
courage which is an oxymoron by the way
it's you can hide behind your avatar and
say anything if you walked into my lobby
and said to my face some of the things
some of you said to me on Twitter it
would not go well for you and you know
that and you know that you know the
courage to do it though so it's not a
problem
and you know I have like 900 thousand
followers on Twitter I have to stop and
think when I get ready to tweet
something that's like 10 football
stadiums full of people if you wouldn't
put it up in front of 10 football
stadiums for people don't put it on
there that's pretty good reminder a
little bit sobering actually makes me go
I probably shouldn't send some stuff on
Twitter I said but had a little too much
fun messing with somebody all on there
right but in it interesting though this
this common denominator of a lack of
civility and it comes out with a guy
like McCain I mean McCain is there's
no possible way unless you are married
to him or one of his kids that you
agreed with everything that got said
there's no way none of his fellow
senators agreed with him all the time in
either party but they respected him
most of the better ones and they can say
something good about him and his
character for instance his courage for
instance his service to his country for
instance does that mean I agree with him
on you know Obama care no does that mean
I agree with him on what no who cares
though who cares the guy passed away
it's kind of family he's got kids have a
little class they'll do some of us good
I'm just it's it's it's time it's time
we got a little bit of civility back and
learn to disagree passionately without
being so dadgum disagreeable
I'm just dumbing including our president
you know he could learn that lesson a
little class wouldn't hurt him you know
I agree with a lot of things he's done a
lot of them love the new tax law oh it's
fabulous
I'm a huge fan but he makes it hard to
be excited if you've got in class I mean
you know so come on guys all of you in
the media my fellow talk radio
screechers out there let's have a little
class especially when it's somebody like
this passes away but i mean i tweeted
billy graham passing away and got
hateful things who hates billy graham i
mean what kind of psychopath
are you really Wow amazing now anyway my
soapbox for the day well like though
every day is not one